We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. here's
an interesting question about a possible bubble
that may be, is about to burst.
Let's take a listen.
Hey David, this is uh, Josh from Kansas city.
I just got a quick question.
I watched some of your videos on the economics
and as far as the recession goes, well I shouldn't
say some your videos on economics, but anyway,
some of your videos about the economy.
Um, you stated that you don't see a bubble
like you did with the housing market, but
okay.
Could the bubble possibly be in the market
itself with all the stock buybacks?
Yes.
I mean, I work on the phones.
It was a customer service rep or financial
industry, no expert.
But it just seems
like that could be a [inaudible]
possible area where the stock is overinflated.
Yeah, you're completely right.
So I've said I don't see a housing market
bubble right now the way we've seen previously.
And in fact, I think that there's been a,
I think I read a 7% decline in housing prices.
I don't remember if that's nationally or here
in Boston or maybe Massachusetts, but there's
no question that there very well may be a
bubble in the stock market.
And what's important to understand is that
bubble may be significantly caused by Donald
Trump's tax reform.
Because as I told you, one of the things that
big corporations have done on the basis of
Donald Trump, Trump's tax reform plan is not
give people raises, uh, not it's not reinvest
back in the company, although anecdotally
that some companies have done that, it's used
the tax a, a windfall to buy back stock, pushing
up the price.
And there indeed may be a stock market bubble.
There may be a lot of retirement accounts
and pensions that are about to take a hit
if and when we see that a pullback.
But I completely agree with a urinalysis.
We've got a great bonus show today.
We will talk about what's going on with Pete
booted judge in Iowa.
We will talk about the cost to become a us
citizen.
There is a cost and it's going up quite a
bit and we will talk about fury over a $50,000
visit by Donald Trump jr, uh, which is now,
um, uh,
if very, very angry with the Florida student
who participated in organizing that visit.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show, become a member and I hope to see you
there.
The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].